William Bruto has been declared winner
of Elections it took place almost a week
ago formerly Kenya's Deputy president he
ran a tightly contested race against the
opposition leader raila odinga this is
him speaking now gospels broke out just
ahead of the announcement and several
election officials say they will contest
the results
let's join DW correspondent Felix
Moringa who's in Nairobi welcome uh
Phoenix so uh talk us through what we
know of the results
so Kenya has a new president William
samway Ruto is the president-elect he
garnered
7.15 million votes representing around
50.49 percent of the total votes cast
and that is the result that the
chairperson of the independent electoral
and boundaries commission has used to
declare William Ruto as the
president-elect William Ruto is the
incumbent was before this particular
moment was the incumbent Deputy
president and now he changes the Mantra
love office he's now been elected he's
now been given the mantle of office to
lead Kenya for the next five years now
William Ruto
um has a deputy by the name regarding
gashaga and the two individuals used the
Hustler narrative which seemed to appeal
more to the young people who much as
it's not so many of them that came out
to vote they still the duo was able to
get 50.49 which was uh more than what
was required because the requirement was
50 percent of the total votes cast and
plus just one vote as you can see behind
me the screen over there that's Deputy
pres the president-elect addressing
Kenyans and he has said that in this in
this particular election there is no
loser all of them are kenyan's end he's
called on the fellow competitors to come
on board and work together which is
um something that we may probably be
seeing in the next few days as rucho
takes the mantle of office so this paves
way for his swearing in should the
election not be contested he will be
sworn in in about the next 14 days and
after that he will now be Kenya's fifth
president okay so 50.49 of the vote
but the vote has been contested tell us
about uh the concerns that have been
raised
so the azimir Coalition side the chief
agent just before the result was
announced came out and addressed the
press and said that uh the IBC systems
had been hacked and that Boomers of
Kenya was a crime scene we also saw some
of the disgruntled azimir Coalition
members inside the bomas Boma Sterling
Hall uh through chairs and it was an
ugly scene inside uh the bombers of
Kenya but that did not stop the
announcement of the results of course
four other Commissioners have again also
addressed the Press just before this
particular announcement and said that
this the the results were the election
and the results generally were collected
in an opaque manner they didn't go into
the details but they said after this
particular declaration they will be
giving more details about the opaqueness
of their election so we shall be waiting
to see what the details will be and
whether this details will actually find
their way to the Supreme Courts so we
have a natural we have the allegation
that the Electoral commission systems
were hacked we have members of The
Electoral commission saying that they do
that they will not stand by the vote has
there been an official response from the
Electoral commission to these
allegations
there hasn't been an official uh
announcement or a response because the
first activity by the Electoral uh
commission chairperson was to announce
the president-elect and that is what has
just taken place the president the
president-elect William Ruto has just
been handed over the certificate that is
form 34d which is the national
declaration form that he is duly elected
as president so three Commissioners uh
stand by the result four Commissioners
do not stand by the result
four Commissioners do not stand by the
results so we wait to see what what
happens after this because it looks like
the commission is divided by half but as
it is Kenya has a new president and the
president-elect is William Samuel Ruto
thank you for that Felix Felix Moringa
in Nairobi